[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
happy
Monday everyone you all look beautiful
well some of you so another weekend
another Biden blunder they're as common
as flatulence and Whoopi Goldberg's
dressing room while delivering a speech
to the Congressional Black Caucus
Saturday night old Joe might have been
trying to tell us something namely that
it's the first time you heard of LL Cool
J
two of the great artists of our time
representing the groundbreaking Legacy
of hip-hop in America
llj Cool J
by the way that boy's got he's got man's
got biceps bigger than my thighs
a tip to bring Joe to the 21st century
try not to call African American males
over the age of 10. boy even if you once
eulogized a close friend who helmed the
Ku Klux Klan
but Joe does know his hip-hop has an
accomplished breakdancer
[Applause]
[Music]
that's black
doesn't even need cardboard
but I wonder what his fellow Dems think
of these gaffes
uh yeah as the gaps pile up newsom's
laughing so hard oil-soaked birds are
falling out of his hair and that was
shocking New Washington Post ABC News
poll has Donald Trump with a whopping
10-point lead over Biden in a
hypothetical rematch of 2020. the only
thing shocking about that is that it's
not a 70 point lead I guess it's time to
get back to what worked in his last
campaign and have Dr Jill lock him in
the basement I wonder what his fellow
Democrats think about that
thank you
[Laughter]
so why do I keep why do I keep bringing
up Gavin well other than my respect for
his work in American Psycho he's
he's starting to distance himself from
his party's worst ideas Newsome a guy
who hates fossil fuels but could still
bring down the price of gas by ringing
out his hair once proclaimed that his
state would be a sanctuary to all who
seek it then people actually came tons
of them moving faster than a mob of
Walgreens shoplifters so last week
Newsome said he hopes the conservative
Supreme Court will overturn the current
law that bans his state from removing
out of control homeless encampments
imagine that what did you expect Gavin
that the sanctuary Seekers were going to
show up in winnebagos once again another
example of a high-profile lib using his
big mouth to write a check his ass can't
cash
last year after the Texas Texas governor
Abbott ordered that parents of
transitioning children should face
criminal investigation Newsome then
tweeted this trans kids and their
families should be celebrated not
targeted by the state they are heroes
and so to fearful families in Texas
right now California's door is always
open to you
yeah and so is the side door on some
pedophiles minivan
then came the national polling by
overwhelming majorities it turns out
Americans don't favor miners
transitioning so last week when a
California law was proposed that judges
in custody cases favor the parent who
supports transitioning a child's new
gender Newsome killed that law quicker
than a late term abortion
yeah I know huh now the left being the
left was outraged but they missed
something because now Newsome says he
only vetoed it since it's already the
law that's a nice one dude you gotta
admit this guy's so oily he should join
OPEC but what a magician only he pulls
excuses out of his butt instead of
rabbits from a hat and that's the
strategy covering his butt because in
the real world these Progressive
policies much like Kamala Harris just
don't work
so people are eventually forced to look
elsewhere Newsom himself is discovering
this the hard way he recently said in an
interview that his kids are on a pathway
to a micro cult by listening to the
likes of Andrew Tate Joe Rogan and
Jordan Peterson but is it a pathway to a
cult or or being saved from their dad's
insane life philosophy because as Scott
Adams points out the harder the left
tries to raise the children on the right
the more Andrew Tate will be raising the
children on the left
and at least no one's trying to sniff
them
I guess in Gavin's world kids could
choose their gender but not their
opinions it's funny the definition of a
cult is keeping people from contacting
people not in the cult and silencing
speech but isn't that what the Dems are
doing to parents and just about anyone
who disagrees with them now perhaps many
lefties begin with good intentions as
they always do and at some level they
believe in all this
but in the end reality always shows up
to ruin things like that great
philosopher Mike Tyson once said
everyone has a plan until they get
punched in the mouth
I learned that sitting next to Dana
and nothing hits harder than a
competitive world where bad guys do
exist and where capitalism unleashes
human potential better than anything
else and where children benefit by
having an actual childhood as for Newsom
he's been saying for months he's got no
plans to run for Prez but this weekend
he didn't exactly say no you may be
termed out here but does cleaning up the
streets of California factor into a
potential presidential run I'm never
going to over promise that in the short
run I mean we are struggling in this
statement homelessness no housing and
homelessness is that a yes or no that
was uh it was a
never-ending response to your question
wow that's a shift
so it seems like the slickest sneakiest
man on Earth is slowly sliding in and
because he's good at this political
theater he could be the next
commander-in-chief especially since the
other options are no laughing matter
what do you want to know I want to give
you I want to give you the opportunity
yes
when he's trying to sleep he counts
bucks instead of sheep oh some making
money on Fox Business Charles pain
he looks and sounds like a pack of
Marlboros comedian Jim Florentine
[Music]
she's so sharp blonde darts throw her
host of Kennedy Saves the World podcast
Kennedy
he mends his clothes with the Seattle
Space Needle New York Times bestselling
author comedian and Barbara NWA world
champion Tyrus
Charles something is up and it's not Joe
Biden but something is going on do you
see the gears in motion what's going on
what do you think is happening
desperation yeah it's just like golly
Paul will have to poll after Paul
amongst Democrats are saying hey we just
this Biden does not do it for us yeah
and uh you know they've got to figure it
out there's one person out there Gavin
Newsom is being very obvious about it
they're really in a serious quandary
they really really are but I got to tell
you he is this he is why people hate
politicians I mean just really just he
is like the poster child the poster man
for just disingenuous dishonest I just
I'm telling you they if they think this
guy is is is going to be their savior I
don't I maybe he's slick maybe he can
talk a few votes in but I just can't see
him winning yeah were you offended by
Joe Biden's uh use of uh certain words
you know and it's it's uh I'm surprised
he didn't save Republicans and somehow
he always comes today like remember that
time he said they gonna put you all back
in Chains
Joe Biden is really
he is so much more racist than anything
I've ever heard or seen from president
Trump former president Trump really I
mean in reality the actions that he's
taken as a lawmaker his opinions the way
he's Talked oh these black kids were
looking at my hair as a swimming pool
and they were shocked and they would rub
them and their curls would come up and
they never saw I mean it's just like
it's almost like uh Edgar Rice Burroughs
novel every time I look at him he's
Tarzan in the modern world and all the
black people like look at him look at
that guy he's the best that's his mind
he's a modern day Tarzan you know it's
about that's funny you know I you think
the way he uh butchered LL Cool J's name
I wonder corn Pop's name was probably
Steve
Jim you're an astute political operator
uh what did you make of Joe's gaffs what
he's trying to pronounce LL Cool J and
yeah I mean well he used it the wrong
way like if he would have just went boy
like Flavor played like oh he's just
doing another rapper because I got a
rapper here they didn't write it write
it the teleprompter no I know
he could have got away if you saw those
Z he's like oh yeah
[Laughter]
sorry no it's all right no but look he
he probably he doesn't know what LL Cool
J is he probably thinks it's a brand of
air conditioners he has no idea
what do you think about Gavin Newsom
what's going on there I don't know I
don't know how they they bump out a
Kamala at a VIP you know put a white
male in there and take her out she's got
too much of an ego to just step aside
she's going to go crazy if they try to
do that plus she had a strong two
percent support so yeah forget that yeah
but she's all she's waiting for that
spot to just open for her and then you
put a white male in there yeah there's
no I don't know how to get I mean they
did it to Bernie they they threw him
under the bus to you know presidential
ones in a row they just gave him a
couple extra houses in Vermont go yeah
you got some extra money just but I
don't know how they could do it yeah
it'd be great if they threw under the
bus because she really likes buses
remember
to be crushed by the very thing that
loves you what a tragic way to end her
political life Kennedy carry so many
parts of it was that girl
laughs
um so many parts of that brilliant
monologue there that you can respond to
I don't even know where to start what is
Gavin up to
um Gavin definitely wants to be
president I think he's been banking on
2028 but at some point these polls and
even ABC News was like that pulls an
outlier and everyone's like that's your
poll yeah that was actually like your
polling and you're saying that you're
pulling and your data is garbage and
they want to throw that away you know
which said that he's 10 points behind
Trump right now it's only going to get
worse like however bad he is now look
where he was six months ago he's so much
worse than he was then where is he going
to be in six months you cannot
conceivably have a person like that as a
nominee and Newsome is the only viable
option for Democrats to slide in right
now Gretchen Whitmer she's damaged you
know they they try and talk about other
people and it's it's not going to happen
but Newsome has enough of an aura about
him that they can Cobble something
together the problem is his policies
have been an utter failure visit any
major city in California and you will be
visiting homeless camps and he is a main
reason that homelessness has exploded in
that state he's never had a solution for
it all he's done is thrown money at it
and that has made it worse it is
interesting though the best candidate
that they have is RFK Jr and they're
treating him like crap all right Tyrus
give us your astute political analysis
well the term Tarzan was used
[Laughter]
Tarzan called me a boy
[Applause]
you know we need to rethink everything
because the one the one thing about
Dementia or getting older that the real
you comes out there's no more filters
the little Jiminy Cricket in your
shoulder that says don't say that he
died so now it's just unfiltered
so now we have to go back I think Corn
Pop got a bad rap yes pretty sure corn
Pop's name was Cornelius yes
and Joe was trying to tell him how cool
his hair is when it gets wet yeah Corn
Pop didn't care so Joe called him Corn
Pop and then probably boy after that so
Corn Pop is the good guy Joe is the bad
guy this is who he is this is it's going
to get worse entertainingly worse
because what's going to happen when he's
in a debate well they'll say a president
Trump and there's no more filter and
he's gonna he's gonna try to outrace
somebody he's assumes racist
to get him to go with him cool could you
imagine him debating Vivek and asking
him to like get him a Slurpee yeah no he
would tell no no
he would not do that because that's
that's just straight up honest racism
that's no no remember he did that he
would do it in a way where he would tell
a story about the founding fathers and
how they built this country so when
immigrants could come from India and
build 7-Elevens yeah so that's what he
did and hand him Slurpees in the
summertime yes
overpriced of course that's how he'll do
it and he'll say and then he'll tell
Vivek he will never say his name vivec
yeah he'll give him a name like monkey
boy
and then look at the audience and be
like what yeah do I say here no one
likes him in his family because at some
point if you
if you had any love from anybody they'd
be enough if he was a boxer you hug him
you put the towel over his head and be
like we're going home man yeah we're
going home we're done here but yeah he
couldn't even read LL yeah could I have
something very quickly here
um obviously Newsome is jocking for
presidential position because he has
agreed to debate Ron DeSantis on this
network yes crazy huh so you wouldn't be
debating someone who's running for
president if you also were running for
president exactly excellent point
they're not the equity pick the
Democratic new Democratic parties about
Equity picks they have their pick makes
no sense to us the Laughing bus lady but
that's their Equity pick
laughing butts lady
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else